الان الى تركيا سبعه ايام فقط امام
المتنافسين على الرئاسات لاقناع الناخبين
الذين لم يمنحوا ايا منهم منهما اصواتا
كافيه لحسم الدوره الاولى في منتصف مايو
الجاري الرئيس المنتهيه ولايه الطيب
اردوغان حصل على
49.52% من الاصوات اي بتقدم يبلغ مليونين
و500 الف صوت على مرشح المعارضه كمالك اما
ممثل المعارضه الذي وعد بالعوده الى
الربيع والديمقراطيه الهادئه لم يقنع اكثر
من
44.9% من الناخبين الذين ادلوا باصواتهم
وسيتنافس المرشحان بشده على اصوات مليونين
و790 الف ناخب اتجهت لصالح المرشح الثالث
سنان اوغان الذي سيعلن لمن سيجير اصواته
في الايام القليله المقبله نتائج الجوله
الاولى مشاهدينا من الانتخابات التركيه لم
تاتي على مستوى تو المعارضه لكن اردوغان
تمكن من الحفاظ على مكانته رغم نتائج
استطلاعات الرئيس فيما يسعى الطرفان الى
جعلها لحظه نصر مع قناعتهما بضروره تغيير
استراتيجيتهما لحسب المعركه النتائج
الطفيفه بين
اردوغانو منحه المعارضه املا في تحقيق
مفاجاه لكن ما هي خطتك لتجار اوبلو اذن
بحسب صحيفه
فان المعارضه بدات تلعب بورقه القوميه
لحمل الاتراك على الانتخاب لصالح لكن ذلك
ينطوي على مجازفه وفق بعض الاراء حيث تحول
خطابك من الحديث عن الربيع الذي ينتظر
تركيا الى خطابات وصفت بالعدوانيه تجاه
اللاجئين حيث تعهد بطرد المهاجرين حاله
فوزه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات